OK, let's talk a little bit about masks briefly.
Donald Trump traveled to Arizona yesterday,
went to a Honeywell facility that is making
masks because we have a pandemic.
And people should be wearing masks.
That factory requires masks.
And Donald Trump refused to wear a mask.
Instead, Trump wore goggles, which is OK.
I mean, fine.
But it's a little weird given that he didn't
wear the mask.
Trump was asked as he was leaving the White
House yesterday on his way to Arizona.
Will you wear a mask?
And Trump said, I will if it is a mask facility.
J. I think it's a bask- facility, right?
If it's a mass facility, I well, yeah, I don't
know if it's a mass facility, but oh, honey,
you go to see Honeywell.
They have done an incredible job on many fronts.
And I'm going to pay my respects to a great
company and a great state.
The state of Arizona they make in ninety five.
Yeah.
They make masks.
As Trump says, if it's a mask facility, Trump
says that he will wear one.
Well as you can see in this video that we
are playing.
There are safety guidelines prominently displayed
at this Honeywell facility and they say please
wear your mask at all times in addition to
observing six feet of social distance as well
as using hand sanitizer.
And yet here is Donald Trump standing 18 inches
from another guy wearing goggles, but no mask
as the guy shows him a mask.
They have a crate of masks in front of them.
You couldn't parody this on Saturday Night
Live.
The factory policy is wear a mask at all times
and Trump puts on goggles, but no mask.
And his aides are also not wearing masks.
Now, why do we care about this?
Is it just disaster porn?
No.
We care about this because more than 60 million
people in this country voted for this guy.
Many of those people see Trump as a demigod
and they do whatever he does.
And if Trump goes to a mask facility and he
doesn't wear a mask, it encourages this exact
type of behavior that we don't need right
now.
So we can laugh it off.
We can say, OK, you know, Trump wore goggles
and no mask.
He's just personally kind of a weird dude
or an idiot, but it doesn't really have an
impact.
This will fuel more right wingers not wearing
masks and actually being opposed to them.
This sends the message that wearing a mask
isn't that important, even when the policy
of a location is masks at all times.
It encourages people to ignore it if they
see Trump ignoring the policy that's in large
print on a TV and probably multiple he views.
Trump's own administration has said covering
your mask is better than not cover covering
your face, rather is better than not covering
your face.
If you don't have a mask, wear a scarf, Trump
said.
Well, they had masks.
It's a mask factory.
I would wear one if they require it.
But then he doesn't.
And of course, that puts people around Trump
at risk, and it puts Trump himself at risk.
The message that is being sent is masks are
no big deal.
Corona virus is no big deal.
Everything's fine.
And yet two thousand three hundred fifty people
died in the United States yesterday.
But remember, he's wearing goggles.
This is the same guy who looked at a solar
eclipse directly.
So it's not a question of Trump's intelligence.
That seems to be lacking.
But how does no one put a mask on the guy?
And it's because of what we call management
by optics.
OK, it's the optics of this is no big deal
and we won.
If Trump hasn't been seen with a mask once
during the entire pandemic and he hasn't and
then he claims we've basically won, we can
start taking apart the pandemic response.
The White House Coronavirus Task Force, rather.
If he then shows up with a mask for the first
time, the optics don't match.
I admit that that's the case.
If you're trying to say we won.
You don't start wearing a mask on week nine
of the pandemic.
This is management by optics, period.
And
that
is very dangerous.